these social media influencers the memes
the chainsaws which I want to talk about
because he is fan there he is on the
cover of in an AP article wielding a
chainsaw his supporters there's videos
of them running chainsaws I even saw a
guy with a chainsaw mask like walking
into the voting booth uh the title of
this article for our listeners is a man
a plan a
chainsaw and that's because mle uh has
presented something called chainsaw plan
uh here this quote at the beginning to
your point he says the cast is trembling
um he yells while brandishing a chainsaw
uh and he presented the chainsaw plan in
central Cordova Province uh in June 2022
it is his blueprint for the wholesale
reform of the state to slash public
spending scrap half the government's
Ministries sell state-owned companies
and eliminate the central bank bank that
all sounds pretty good to a
Libertarian if he is elected what are
the political realities how much of that
of his agenda do you believe that he
could
accomplish well that's a that's a good
question uh because it's it's key to
what many voters are considering uh when
thinking about voting for mle um the
reality is that if he get elected
president um his party will not have
more than
15% uh of Congress seats neither in the
House of Representatives nor in the
Senate so he will command a minority uh
and not even the first one uh the first
minority will be the paranis party then
you will have the hoso Coalition if it
still exists and otherwise you will have
many small parties and then you get his
uh so he will not have more than 15% of
of all Congress people which is going to
be a problem for sure if he doesn't cut
any alliances you know uh now the
question is after Bull's endorsement uh
last night um and we're expecting a an
endorsement by a formal endorsement by
President mrie who's just he has
informally endorsed him but not
officially yet um if he cuts an alliance
with them um he may increase uh the size
of his you know legislative uh group uh
but it's going to be hard for him to
form majorities in Congress and then
there's the question of who um who would
be you know part of his team of his
economic team uh who would be uh his um
ministers his minister of economy for
example uh we don't really know much
about that there's some expectation that
um an alliance with bullich and MRE will
provide him with the kind of people you
know he needs people with the expertise
people who know what the challenges uh
inside the state are um but it's it's
unclear really uh what would happen also
because after you know he won the August
primaries and there was this Panic you
know uh in markets he sort of um backed
down in a way from his
proposals because before that he was
just saying he was talking about
dollarization but there were no
specifics in the program and it just
seemed like he would dollarize the
economy on day one you know but after
the August primary and to try to calm
everyone down he said you know
dollarization uh is something that will
happen um in the not in the long term
but not immediately either you know like
in 12 months or 24 months and there will
be a transition period and things will
be smooth you know so as to not hurt
people so in a way it's unclear exactly
what he will do and with whom he will do
um all of the all of his proposals which
is what's scaring people now you know
many people um on the center right are
thinking well the election is over um
even if I vote for mle he's probably
gonna lose but if he wins he will not be
able to do anything so many people I I I
what I sense these days is a lot of um
of sadness you know on the Senate
righteous because M didn't do better uh
on the Sunday election and because um
the math doesn't really add up neither
for the runoff nor for a potential
Administration but you know Argentina is
like a Pandora box Everything Changes uh
significantly like you know week to week
so everything could change how how much
autonomy or you know how much
cooperation would he need in order to
push that the what's really the central
proposition of his campaign the dollariz
the abolition of the central bank is
that something he would have much leeway
in doing even if he had a uncooperative
legislature um and is there a way we
talked about a little bit the beginning
but is there a way to implement
dollarization do you think that would
not create the sort of nightmare
scenario that spooked the
markets well
um the alternative you know to to
hyperinflation if you want to dollarize
is to borrow money basically and now
that's where you know mle's capacity to
attract
Investments um get sort of called into
question um if mle for example were to
um seal you know an alliance a a a an
executive alliance with bullich or
mocker then those people may be able to
uh convince you know investors to borrow
to lend the Argentine State money so
that the state actually has some dollars
you know to dollarize and so that the
exchange rate doesn't need to go to the
through the roof uh that's that's the
alternative um it will require that the
state uh take a lot of debt um it's
unclear whether mle would be able to do
that and if he were to do that then he
would have to
proceed with his fiscal adjustment plan
much more quickly than expected because
he would have to pay that dep down of
course um and the state is already in
deped so that would be a problem um and
uh what was the first question I I I
forgot about that sorry uh it was just
could he how much buyin does he need
from and and he needs yeah
and I'm not sure about uh Tech
technicalities um yeah I think that um
he may have people on his legal team
trying to figure out whether he could
bypass Congress for many of the
proposals uh that he wants to implement
I'm not sure he can do that um Argentine
presidents do get a lot of leeway
through decrees but there are some areas
in which um it is constitutionally
forbidden to issue decrees I don't think
I'm not sure if monetary policy fits
into one of those categories I don't
think so um but it's likely that if M
does something that Congress doesn't
like uh Congress does have the authority
to override a decree you know uh if
Congress gets two-thirds of a majority
then they can override whatever it is
that the government is trying to do um
and so if that's the case and M can't
get one-third of Congress to to support
him then he would be in danger um he
would be in my view the the most
important danger that he would face as
president is um that he would get
impeached uh impeachment would be would
be a real possibility because if he only
has 15% of the vote you know he's just
you know
uh whatever he does that the opposition
doesn't like they will turn that into
uh grounds for impeachment and it will
impeach him for sure um if he's
unpopular enough of course if if that if
the opposition thinks that it will be in
their benefit to impeach M they will do
it uh that's of course assuming he will
actually get elected president but I
think that's the that he he's his
biggest concern right now should be that
really because the the election for
Congress has been done already that's
not going to change with the runoff and
he will just not have uh many congress
people so that's what I would be
focusing on right now how to avoid
impeachment on day one or day two yeah
hey thanks for watching that clip of our
talk with Marcos Falcone about the
presidential candidacy of Javier Malay
you can watch the full conversation here
or another clip over here